he wrote these books notebooks that
haven't been published yet called the
block books and the black books are the
documentation of his experiments with
his imagination and what he would do is
daydream like like a child daydreams he
regained that Faculty although I think
with you MIT was a faculty that have
never really disappeared and he had
figures of imagination that came to him
that he could speak with and he spoke
with these figures of imagination and
documented that over a very long period
of time and that was originally that was
eventually distilled into a book called
the red book which was published about
three or four years ago and it was a
book that young regarded as the central
source from which all his inspiration
emerged I'm a sort of the way it looks
to me is that we embody a lot of
information in our action right and our
action has developed as a consequence of
imitating other people and not only the
people the people around us but of
course the people around us imitated the
people who came before them and those
people in MIT ated the people who came
before them and so on so far back that
it's as far back as you can go and so
you embody these patterns of behavior
that are extremely informative that you
don't understand that are a consequence
of collective imitation across the
centuries and so then those patterns can
become manifest as figures of the
imagination and those figures of
imagination are the distillation zuv
patterns of behavior and so as the
distillation zuv patterns of behavior
they have content and it's not you that
content it's you could even think about
it as content that's evolved although
it's culturally transmitted this content
that's evolved and so these figures of
the imagination can reveal the structure
of reality to you and that's what
happened with Jung and that's what he
described in the red book and that was
what permeated his psychology a
psychology that was based on the
presupposition that the fundamental ARCA
temple structures of religious belief
were not pathological not deceitful not
protective in some delusional sense
against the fear of death but quite the
contrary the very stories that enabled
us to move forward as confident human
beings in the face of chaos itself and
it's conceivable
I think perhaps probable that nothing
more important conceptually happened in
the 20th century than that
because it was the first time post
enlightenment that ever approached montt
between the intellect and the underlying
religious archetypal sub structure
occurred you have in the capacious
intellect of Jung and the same thing
happened to some degree with Piaget the
religious domain and the factual domain
were brought back together and the fact
of Jung's enduring and increasing
popularity and influence I would say is
a direct consequence of that now some of
his work was spun off into the new age
and and the new age is a very optimistic
and naive movement it's predicated on
the idea that you can do nothing say but
follow your bliss and that will take you
ever higher to enlightenment and that's
not the Union idea at all the Union idea
is that what you most need will be found
where you least want to look so there's
this story King Arthur there's this
story of King Arthur that they're all in
a round table right King Arthur and his
knights they're all equals they're all
superordinate but they're all equals and
they go off to look for the Holy Grail
from the Holy Grail Grail is the
container of the redemptive substance
whatever that is it might be the cup
that Christ used at the Last Supper
might be jealous that was used to
capture his blood on the cross right
when he was pierced by a sword the
stories differ but that's the Holy Grail
and the Holy Grail is lost that's the
redemptive substance and the Knights of
King Arthur go off
to search for the Holy Grail and but
they don't know where to look so where
do you look when you don't know where to
look for something you need desperately
but I've lost well each of the Knights
goes into the forest at the point that
looks darkest to him and that's Jungian
psychoanalysis in a nutshell
it's like that which you fear and avoid
that's which you hold in contempt that
which disgusts you and that you avoid
that's the gateway to what you need to
know there's nothing new age about that
that's for sure